OK?
I really need everybody to understand this
because this is so important.
The strategy by Donald Trump of saying that
the election will be unfair and rigged is
working.
If it wasn't convincing anybody, we could
ignore it.
It might be no big deal, but it is working.
Donald Trump has convinced 65 percent of Republican
voters that the upcoming election might not
be fair.
This is a poll based on more than 44000 U.S.
adults with a one percent margin of error.
Now, here's what makes this really tricky.
Sixty five percent of Republicans questioned
whether the election will be fair.
Forty six percent of Democrats also aren't
confident that the election will be fair.
But the devil is in the details because the
concerns about fairness from Republicans are
very different than the concerns about fairness
from the Democrats.
And it really comes down to understanding
these details.
Republicans who think the election might not
be fair are falling for what Donald Trump
has been saying, which is mail in ballots
will be riddled with fraud.
We won't know the election results for a long
time.
They are rigging it.
That's what the Republican voters have fallen
for.
Democrats, on the other hand, are worried
that Trump is making the election not fair.
By breaking the post office, by filing lawsuits,
by trying to suppress the vote, so on and
so forth, preventing vote by mail, purging
voter rolls, doing all of the things that
Republicans have been doing for decades to
try to win elections by suppressing the vote.
So these are not asymmetrical concerns.
If you glance at the numbers and you say,
OK, well, it seems like Republicans or Democrats
and Democrats are basically in agreement just
to slightly different degrees.
Forty six percent of Dems think the election
might be unfair.
Sixty five percent of Republicans, no big
deal, slight party difference.
The reasons why they think there might not
be fairness are what is so dramatically different.
And what you have to understand in order to
really synthesize this properly is the history
of voter suppression historically.
Democrats try to increase voter turnout, period.
They just say if more people vote, we're better
off in general.
Republicans have employed a strategy of trying
to limit voter turnout in very particular
and specific ways.
Polling shows that it's Trump who will most
likely or more likely need foul play in order
to win.
Democrats simply want the election to happen.
They want everybody who wants to vote to get
to vote, and they want every single one of
those votes to be counted.
And it's true.
If that happens, it's better for Joe Biden.
We know that.
To be true, the president is the one who realizes
that he might need voter fraud and voter suppression
to win.
As I told you in the last segment, and the
scariest thing is that it's working for Donald
Trump, are concerned for a long time, has
been if it's close in November.
And Trump claims it was rigged and it activates
his followers, many with their guns, to hit
the streets.
That could get very ugly and it could happen
very quickly.
It could happen within hours of whenever Trump
claims the rigging took place.
So when we hear that there are no gaps in
the confidence people have in our voting systems,
we can't forget that one side is the side
that tries to lower turnout in order to win,
meaning a ton of Trump ists are happy that
the election might not be fair.
This has always been the point of attacking
it.
And this is why it will continue unless we
stop it.
This is how it starts.
This is how you weaponize people to hit the
streets, maybe with guns to demand that you
be kept in power.
These are not inconsequential or trivial matters.
Now, what can we do?
If you want to find out how and where you
can vote early, check out the page called
Early Voting by State on Vote Dawg.
We're linking to that page in the description
to the YouTube video for this story.
And you will very quickly see that every state
is different here in Massachusetts, for example.
Early voting starts 11 days before this is
in-person.
Early voting starts 11 days before the election.
In Michigan, it starts 45 days before the
election.
We're getting close to that in Florida.
It's early voting starts at least 10 days
before the election.
If not earlier.
So understand that.
Understand what the rules are for voting absentee
in your state.
You probably in most states, you probably
already can request an absentee ballot.
I've already done it.
I've received my primary ballot for the September
1st election.
And sometime after September 1st, I'm going
to be receiving my absentee ballot for the
general election in November.
Understand all of these things.
Figure out how you plan to vote.
And then let's activate whoever we can and
make sure that people that are already on
our side plan to vote.
Particularly when, you know, Trump wants to
make it difficult to vote.
But the reality is, in most states, it's actually
easier than ever to vote.
With early voting, with expanded absentee
ballot access, there's no excuse for not voting
this time around in many people.
Metaphorically.
This time around are willing to crawl over
broken glass in over two in order to vote.
Some would literally do it.
I'm using it metaphorically.